Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Yeah.
Ah,
just checking in.
Hey,
uh,
you,
who,
what's going on?
Just checking in on you.
How's your Thursday afternoon going?
Oh,
Billy Billy Ballou.
He left Ireland.
He left Dublin for fuck sakes.
And um,
now I'm in a,
I'm in London.
I,
I flew into a fro.
Yeah.
Um,
the typical Heathrow experiences just,
I just don't fucking understand what the problem is with that God damn airport.
I hate that fucking airport.
I love it because I'm going to London,
but I hate it when I get there.
Oh,
I was flying from Dublin to London,
which is like flying from fucking La to San Francisco,
essentially.
Nice.
Easy flight.
Okay.
You're on southwest.
They're doing stand up,
you're waiting for it to be over.
And by the time they finished their routine,
they already landing and they've begun where there were now landing routine with
him,
imitate fucking c three Po and fucking Darth Vader or whatever it is that those
people are trying to do over there.
MMM.
Anyways,
I guess they feel like there's a lot of nervous flyers over there.
And for some reason,
bad standup comedy is the thing,
I guess.
Then you're not afraid to die because you're like,
well,
at least if the plane crashes,
I don't have to hear the end of this routine.
Oh,
Bill,
that's no way to,
it's Thursday,
man.
It's supposed to be a happy event.
Yeah.
So anyways,
I'm flying from Dublin and to eighth row and um,
everything's goes great.
Take off on time.
Land a little bit.
Early Gate is ready,
you know.
But I did the unforgivable,
I checked a bag,
which I never do,
I didn't want to do on this trip,
but you know,
my wife talked me into it.
Um,
which I'm actually glad she did.
Once I get the bag and I unpack and actually have some of my stuff,
you know,
I have some options for different outfits.
Sorry.
MMM.
So everything goes great.
And then,
you know,
I get off the plane,
I'm standing there,
I get the information.
Oh,
I don't have to go through customs because that was already fucking in Dublin or
whatever,
which I didn't think was part of the,
uh,
the whole Great Britain fucking reach.
I th I would think if I was in Northern Ireland,
if I felt food from Belfast to London,
they'd be like,
all right.
I was in the Republic of Ireland,
you know,
I was there.
They're not part of Great Britain.
Are they other Great Britain?
Was,
was,
uh,
England,
Wales,
Scotland
and Northern Ireland.
Yeah,
whatever.
Okay.
Maybe because I'm in the European Union,
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but then I thought they did the Brexit thing,
but maybe that hasn't happened yet.
I don't know.
All I know is I haven't gone through,
I didn't have to go through customs,
so I was sacked and I go down to the fucking stupid carousel thing,
whatever,
the baggage claim.
Okay.
And it's already turned on.
I'm like,
you fucking kidding me.
And I see three bags come out.
Then there's a little space,
little space,
and I see two bags coming out.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
They're already unloading it.
So I stand there for a good five minutes and it's just those three bags,
little space,
little space that then the two bags and then I start recognizing the bag saying,
oh,
these are just bags that were sitting here.
You know,
five people didn't make it,
were sold in the human trafficking and they haven't claimed their bags.
I Dunno what the fuck happened,
right?
Um,
or they went ahead of their flight or their bags got on and they didn't know who
the fuck notes.
And I was standing there.
10 minutes goes by,
15 minutes goes by,
20 minutes goes by the belts on the same fucking three bags,
a little bit of space.
So the space,
it was fucking two bags.
And um,
I'm just like,
you know,
this is just every fuck I went up to stand there for like 50 fucking minutes,
wait for my fucking bag.
It's just like that fucking airport.
It just breaks you goddamn spirit.
Cause every fucking time it's a different fuck over a c and never see it coming.
If that always happened,
I would be like,
okay,
here's the deal.
I'm not checking a bag.
Or if I checked the bag,
it'd be like,
just settle in because you know it's going to be 50 minutes.
All right,
go sit down,
get yourself some bangers and mash,
whatever the fuck it is.
These people lead over here and you know,
show up 45 minutes later and pick up your fucking bag.
What killed me is how everybody else just accepted it and I was the only person
standing there going,
what the fuck is wrong with this airport?
What do they got?
Three fucking baggage handlers.
Then what kills me is when that they finally started unloading the bags,
they unload like five of them
and then,
and then you see people on your flight grabbing them and then there's no more
bags for like 10 minutes.
It's like,
what the fuck happened?
The guy doing it just to,
just to have a fucking stroke.
Okay.
There's nobody back there to help them.
You get like concerned?
MMM.
Oh,
why didn't I wasn't concerned.
I was selfish.
I'll,
he gave his show was about was my bag.
So anyways,
I get my fucking bag.
Yeah.
And uh,
I make it over here to the hotel.
And,
uh,
after the night before I was played the three arena in Dublin,
one of my favorite shows,
those fucking people are just
okay.
And it's like double specific to,
to Dublin.
They like the best fucking hecklers.
I don't even know
how,
but they made like nine 11.
Funny.
Oh,
just in an absurd way.
I was on stage and I was talking about like how much the country changed,
you know,
since nine 11 when I said nine 11,
somebody in the crowd went,
whew.
You know,
and they might've been in American agreeing like,
Ooh,
yeah.
You know,
the country did really change after that.
Just kind of an obvious statement.
Now that I'm repeating it,
but the way they did it,
it made it seem like they were cheering on nine 11.
So I riffed about that.
I said,
Oh yeah,
you excited about tragedies?
Oh yeah.
I,
you know,
I've always hated skyscrapers.
I just said something like that.
It made everybody laugh.
So then I started the joke again,
add it,
go,
you know,
ever since nine 11.
And then the whole crowd goes,
Woo,
just to be Dicks,
you know,
still that I roll with it and I just start,
start every fucking joke now with some American tragedy as go,
yeah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
I believe that was around,
uh,
Pearl Harbor.
And then they'll all go,
woo,
Ooh,
so fucking childish and stupid.
Right?
So after like the third one,
I said,
I got,
you know what Ireland,
I really wish I knew about your fucking tragedies.
All right.
But I'm an American.
I don't have time to care about other countries.
And it was just like this little fucking stupid inside back and forth thing that
will never happen at another show.
Um,
and uh,
I dunno,
it was just the classic classic,
Dublin crab.
MMM.
I had such a fucking great,
I came,
it's just such a fucking great city.
So then I go over,
uh,
last night to do Royal Albert Hall and um,
I don't even know how to describe it.
Like,
uh,
I still feel like it was like,
I dreamed it,
like it didn't really hit,
it went by so God damn fast.
And when you walk in there,
if you're a fan of led zap on that place essentially looks the exact same as it
did when you watch,
you know,
that concert footage,
the outline for my money,
the best concert footage,
um,
of led Zeppelin that exists just the way it looks,
the way it's shot that film.
Um,
I've tried to do a stand up special to make it look like that.
You just can't do it.
It's just of that,
yeah,
I guess you'd have to film it,
but,
um,
I just walked right down.
It was like John Bonham's fucking that,
that maple kit he had was right fucking here.
It was crazy.
And I'm on when,
when I got announced to go out,
I can't remember it was that constant or not.
There's one word,
Robert plant walks off stage and grabs a joint,
smokes it and holds it up to the camera.
Like that's what I thought.
It was such a fucking,
it was the weirdest experience walking out because I felt like I'd been there
already just because I've watched that concert film so many times and no,
I didn't get a chance to play drums because,
uh,
I did the show in Dublin the night before,
which I had to do,
cause you know,
I had to make sure,
um,
I did one show in Europe,
you know,
if there's always that,
just a little bit of a different vibe.
So I had,
you know,
that was more important,
to have a good show then to,
you know,
go there and hack away at the drums for like an hour.
But,
um,
I believe me,
I definitely got my money's worth.
The crowd was fucking amazing.
Um,
and I just had this whole weird feeling the entire time I was up there.
Like,
why am I so relaxed with a combination of,
Holy Shit,
I'm in Royal Albert Hall
and then,
you know,
actually fucked up a couple of jokes because I was looking at the architecture.
I can't fucking believe I'm here.
Um,
my parents came out,
my wife came out for the show.
Um,
my manager and agent came out and,
uh,
it was just awesome.
It was like everybody,
you know,
I,
I can't eat if you ever get a chance to come over here and see anything there.
Um,
it really is just one of those places.
And I put some photos up on Instagram and um,
Yup,
that's it.
And now,
now Billy boy is on vacation.
I think I did like an hour and 15 minutes in the show and I was sitting there
going,
I forgot to look at my watch.
And I was like,
I can't tell if I've been up here for an hour and a half,
40 minutes,
a half hour,
or a little over an hour.
Cause I,
I,
I dunno,
I don't think since Carnegie Hall,
there's been a couple of places that you play and you're just like,
um,
I shouldn't be here.
That's what you're thinking.
Just looking at how beautiful it is and then seeing like when you walk to the
dressing room,
you can't help but look at the photos and I'm looking like everyone from Freddie
Mercury,
David Bowie,
Frank Sinatra
in like 1963,
evidently the fucking Beatles and the rolling stones played there on the same
bill,
you know,
and then I'm walking out there going like,
hey,
you know what the fuck's up with chairs and you just,
you know,
your act just,
just,
just shrinks down either.
I was kind of the thing you had to like fight off.
But,
um,
my agent asked me like,
after the show,
he goes,
so what venue do you want to play next year in London?
I was like,
ah,
this one,
you know,
where the fuck do you go from here?
Um,
and they're all like,
well,
you know,
it's like booked three years out.
I'm like,
I don't give a shit.
I don't care,
you know?
Um,
unbelievable.
So thank you so much to everybody who came out to the show.
And afterwards I was able to,
uh,
you know,
run out there and say a to some people,
signed some posters and uh,
I appreciate the people that hung out and were patient because like I said,
it had a lot of family and friends back there.
You know,
it was sorta my pre birthday celebration,
they had a cake and shit like that,
so I had to do that and I ran out there.
So you got tired of waiting for me and you left.
I apologize.
But uh,
for the record I did come out.
MMM.
And the people there were just like ridiculously nice annual,
there's all these people.
I had like three people from Poland going,
you got to deal with Shell in Poland.
MMM.
Somebody from Romania,
somebody from Jordan.
When I was in Dublin,
I did a show.
There was this dude from Hong Kong told me he flew in because he saw a clip of
me on Conan O'brien.
How fucking crazy as the internet,
that's as some guy in Hong Kong watching clips of the Conan O'brien show.
And then he sees me as a guest,
Colin and makes me look good is always,
and now he wants to come to my show.
He w he goes,
I got tickets for the,
the Dublin show and the London show and he was there by himself.
I was just like,
all right,
this guy's either going to stab me or this is one of the coolest people I've
ever met in my life.
Fortunately it was the latter.
So,
um,
anyways,
now I'm on vacation.
I'm on vacation.
Do you guys realize the next part?
This is my last podcast in my forties,
man.
Oh,
fucking Billy over the hill.
Where to dude,
dude,
I'm turning fucking 50 on Sunday,
Sunday,
Sunday.
Um,
actually feel good.
You know,
I don't,
I'm not going to feel any fucking different.
I don't think between now and Sunday.
Other than when somebody says,
how old are you?
I don't say for I say fear now.
50.
Um,
that's it.
Oh,
Billy.
Billy red nuts is 50 fucking years old.
Who would have thunk it?
Um,
so anyways,
so then we ended up hanging out.
We went out to a bar afterwards,
only had a couple of drinks,
smoked an unbelievable cigar and
mmm.
Then there was like this little casino thing that we went to.
Me and my manager,
my agent and my lovely wife,
um,
or did some dim sum at like fucking two in the morning and we watched a game for
the NBA finals.
Uh,
which was a great game once again,
but it's just golden state has too many fucking too many people.
Man.
It's like a,
I dunno,
I guess it's genius that the Nva let's these teams
become what they are,
I guess with all the fucking everybody piling on because then guys like me,
I just watch rooting against that team.
Um,
but um,
you know,
it's kind of boring though,
the last two years again,
VA kind of knowing at the beginning of the season,
well yeah,
obviously these guys are going to win it and then they do,
I mean this is not even like,
I dunno,
remember that year of [inaudible],
you know what,
I couldn't get into,
I couldn't get into the Dream Team when we went to the Olympics and they would
dunk it on Ethiopians and shit.
It was just like this,
just like this is,
it was the most boring fucking,
and they always talk about that team.
Well that was the way it is.
Assemblage of talent in basketball history.
Yeah.
Going up against probably the weakest.
I would rather watch the Globetrotters play the fucking Washington generals.
They watched the Dream Team pay for play fucking Rwanda or whatever the hell we
were doing that year.
You know what I mean?
But what was good about that
was they so kicked the shit out of everybody that sense then,
you know,
Europe,
like raise the bar the way they play now and now some of the best players in the
league or from Europe,
which was unheard of when I was growing up.
So I guess,
I don't know,
something good will come out of this golden state warrior team that they'll just
be,
I don't know,
all the stars will be on two teams.
They,
she just take the all star team in the east and the West.
Right.
And just,
just have that be the league.
Right.
Or at least just have him go to the NBA finals and then you just get what to
watch.
Everybody try
as opposed to the all star game and nobody pays any defense.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
okay.
So anyways,
uh,
that's it man.
I did Royal Albert Hall.
Part of the history of freckles is part of that.
I can't fucking believe it.
Can't believe it.
I was saying that to somebody.
I say you believe fucking 26 years ago,
you sign up for a stupid fucking open mic and it leads to this.
MMM.
Never.
Never in my wildest dreams where I ever think I would ever sell one ticket in
London,
you know,
or any place in Europe.
Forget about getting to play that place.
So that one,
you know,
there's ones that stay you.
Um,
that's definitely one.
you know,
the nine 11 shelf that will stay with me.
The absurdity of that,
the vicar street one that I did Dublin,
um,
I had a great one in Oslow,
my first really good show in Europe.
These are all of the European ones that stick it.
Germany was fun when I was teasing him about Hitler.
I've had so much fucking fun over here.
Um,
I just got to figure out how to do these dates now that I got the Kiddo,
but everybody's over here,
by the way.
My lovely daughter is here.
She's such a riot.
She woke up this morning.
I stayed out late.
Right.
So
obviously she,
you know,
mia gets her up and everything.
She puts her in the bed.
She's next to me and I have my eyes closed.
And then she just,
I just,
it looks over at me.
She just goes,
hi.
Yeah.
I start cracking up and then she left.
And that's,
that's just the greatest way ever to start the date.
Nia,
how much fun was last night?
Oh,
that's great.
That's really great.
Um,
what are we doing today?
We're got to go get some bangers and mash and mushy peas.
Yeah.
Okay.
You look beautiful.
Nini.
Thank you.
I like your dress.
So what we're going to do today,
hey,
if anybody lives in here,
our lives around in London,
if you know a place where they have good food,
uh,
please text me.
The dim sung actually was great last night,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
We've been kind of striking out here.
I know there has to be good food here.
There has to be.
Okay.
Everybody has the food network.
There has to be some food in London that's actually seasoned correctly.
Um,
I don't under,
I just don't get it.
You know,
I mean,
they got salt and pepper,
but after that it just goes off the rails.
That fucking guy that,
uh,
the hell's kitchen guys from here,
people from here can cook.
Where the fuck are they?
Gordon Ramsay?
Does he got a receipt?
Well,
I don't know if I want to go to his restaurant because you know,
those celebrity chefs,
they loaned their name to something.
It's hit or miss.
Some of them are involved.
Other rooms just like how much.
Yeah.
I don't give a shit what my fucking name on it.
Um,
anyways,
so tonight I'm going to try to find a place where I can watch potentially the
Washington capitals when their first Stanley Cup,
the bed in the league since 1974,
God bless 'em if 45th season,
I really want to see a vet.
You can get a cup,
you know?
Um,
I dunno,
I,
but also,
you know,
then the other side is if Vegas comes back,
and every Washington capitol fan just fucking hung their head because they know
if anybody could blow a fucking three,
one lead.
But I,
I just think this,
this capital's team is different.
I'm not trying to chink some or anything like that.
I'm just going to fucking,
you know,
I'm not any of that stupid sports chink shit.
Okay.
This fucking team,
like,
you know,
the coaching
that's going on here,
you know,
they saw who the nights were and gave one and they said,
oh,
is that how you applied?
Well,
here's our adjustment to it.
And God dammit,
they've won the next three in a row.
And I really hope I get to find a place where I can watch that game.
Maybe I'll go back down to the casino again.
MMM.
And watch it.
But,
uh,
Oh man,
that reminds me of this time.
I watched a patriots game when I was in Australia at a fucking casino at like
four in the morning.
I think
it was four in the morning the next day.
And I was watching son was four in the morning on Monday in Australia and I was
watching Sunday afternoon football.
It's like a 14.
I think I was watching the one o'clock game or something.
It's like a 14 hour.
Is it a 14 hour difference?
No,
it's like that's how long the flight is,
is 14 hours.
I can't fucking remember.
It's something ridiculous like that.
MMM.
So anyways,
I don't even know if I have any fucking advertising.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know what to tell you.
That's it.
It's actually sunny out here in London.
I was worried that it was going to be all fucking shitty weather.
Oh by the way,
you know I ended up being like ridiculous traffic getting to the um,
yeah.
Getting to the venue last night cause they were building some new hotel called
the mandarin out here and they had some massive fire like half something like
half the firefighters in,
in all of London where they're fighting the fucking thing.
Thank God.
Like you know the hotel wasn't open yet,
although that wasn't what I was saying in my show.
I was so upset about the fucking traffic.
I was saying I was wishing it was full of people.
Maybe they would have been less traffic on the road.
Oh,
Bill.
Why would you,
why?
Why?
Okay.
Why would you say something like that?
Um,
so that fucking burned down.
It's probably an insurance job.
You know,
I wonder,
I wonder if they can actually looked that up right now on my European Internet,
which is going to have all kinds of shit,
dude.
They literally had an advertisement for fucking field hockey over here.
It's like field hockey.
Is that a,
that's a,
that's a sport
like on TV sport.
I know it's a sport.
Okay.
They just got some weird shit over here when it comes to this sports stuff,
you know,
and let me guess.
I'm not fucking signed in.
Right.
Uh,
you fucking so and so Wifi.
Enter your room number and to your last name.
You know,
I went to the casino last night,
they asked for my driver's license.
They wanted to take like a fucking picture of me and I was in such a good mood.
I let them do all of that.
I'm like,
well,
I guess I in your system now.
They go,
no,
we don't.
We don't.
We don't keep it.
It's like,
yeah,
you do.
You're taking a fucking picture of me.
Like where?
Where does all of that go?
You know,
I just got a fucking phone call,
a message from American Airlines saying that somebody's got my,
a frequent flyer number in,
might've been trying to see where I was flying and blah,
Blah Blah and all of this bullshit.
And it's just like,
so we need you,
uh,
you know,
we need you to call us and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
what the fuck do I got to call you guys for?
Why don't you guys fix your fucking weak ass system?
This isn't on me.
I love like when when like your information might've been compromised,
you call them up and they tell you what you need to do.
It's like,
no,
you know what you need to do.
Stop putting everything up on fucking computers.
Go back to fucking notebooks and pens
so far,
like the paper trail that you leave.
It's really impossible now.
Okay.
That's what it fucking kills me about that guy that almost went to jail,
but he sat next to Larry David.
If the Dodgers game,
it's like there was no record of that guy anywhere paying for parking,
getting a hot dog,
his cell phone.
They couldn't track it to the game.
You know,
he didn't go through some intersection where there was a camera with his dodger
hat on going into fucking
Carlito's way canyon,
wherever the fucking Dodgers play.
Um,
Carlitos Canyon.
What the hell is it called?
Chavez Ravine.
Huh?
I don't know.
Anyways,
what the fuck was I looking up?
Oh,
London fire.
So I'm going to do a bunch of touristy shit,
I think today with my parents.
Hopefully if they're up for it,
you know,
I don't think I've ever seen Buckingham Palace.
I liked that dude who just got married by the way.
I don't know.
There's just something about his face.
She like this.
I,
you know,
you can just see how much he's going to annoy the shit out of his wife
accidentally.
Come on,
man for can you fucking just for once the Internet.
Can you work for me?
London Fire Hotel Safari.
Can't verify the oh,
continue.
I don't give a shit.
My stuff's already been compromised.
Login.
I did log in.
Please select.
Do you accept the terms that we're going to take all of your shit and then call
you later and say somebody that we don't know.
Got It.
And they're now in the dark web looking at fucking kitty porn.
All right,
you are logged in.
Okay,
wonderful.
London is the last time I'm trying this.
Everybody.
London Fire
Bill Burns Burns it up last night at the fucking,
sorry.
Ego just kicked in.
Yeah.
The London Fire Brigade.
No,
that's not what I want.
Fire Brigade.
That sounds like a fucking musical
hotel.
Fire
fucking London.
All right,
here we go.
What do we got here?
Mandarin Oriental.
Huge blaze.
Oh Dude,
look at that fucking thing.
Sorry.
You need flash to play this.
Enable it in your browser out.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Plumes of smoke.
Hey look who's here.
Hi.
Huh?
How you doing buddy?
Oh,
okay,
cool.
And totally be out of here.
So she can do that.
Okay.
You got it.
All right.
Bye.
A total of 36 hotel guests and 250 members of the hotel staff were evacuated.
All there were fucking people in their singer.
Robbie Williams was among them.
Uh,
I dunno who Robbie Williams is.
It sounds like a teen idol,
even if he's old or she,
right.
The blaze reach or they,
okay.
The blaze reached several floors but was quickly extinguished or those,
the London Fire Brigade set,
uh,
the London Fire Brigade,
Nia,
the fire brigade,
not to firefighters.
Again,
not the fucking Hook and ladder.
What welcomed?
They never do the hook and lateral play anymore in the NFL?
Never one of that.
It always seemed to work back in the day.
That's what I'm saying.
Huh?
It's like,
what?
Are you going to watch the NHL hockey with me tonight?
No.
Why not?
You love sports.
You just don't realize it yet.
Oh,
I'm,
I'm looking for something I had to ask you about hearing your podcast.
I'll let me hit pause.
She's gonna take her around.
All right.
Um,
all right.
Sorry about that.
I'm just planning our damn day here.
Billows and belows,
Robbie Williams 44 describes the drama.
I went on the balcony and looked up and there was just billows and billows of
smoke.
I came back in from the balcony and said,
the hotel's on fire.
Oh,
this guy's a smart fucking so smart guy.
And then the hotel's on fire and there's a lot of smoke.
But I mean,
what else would you say?
He really,
he got the information out.
The hotel's on fire.
I probably would have came back in and wouldn't be like,
yeah,
what the fuck date I was,
you know,
added all these extra words.
And then the next thing,
a knock at the door came and there was a bellboy there and they said,
get out.
I like this.
This is very,
who's that playwright that just has really fucking choppy dialogue like that.
Or like when you watch law and order,
you know,
they have to get so much information and they actually timed your lines.
When you do an episode of that show,
they don't care about emotion that just like say it faster.
All right.
Williams and his wife,
Ida felled 39 ran down and external fire escape to safety.
Oh,
there's a video.
I don't need flash for that.
Oh man,
that's a beautiful hotel.
I thought it was under construction.
Wait a minute.
Wow.
You know what billows and billows of smoke?
Well,
what started it
all right.
Can't emphasize enough how well the of actuation operation isn't put together
now being moved to a nearby hotel for safety.
Well,
who gives a fuck about you?
Ah,
you can't say that.
This is how it is.
Every dev,
even things about everybody now,
right?
Hotel's on fire.
Shaking my head.
Lol.
Fuck my life.
Yolo.
He's a guy.
Just wrote,
hope you work are okay.
Anna,
subtext.
Uh,
I'd like to comfort you slash maybe turning it into some sort of sexual
activity.
Um,
all right,
I think that's a good place to end.
Um,
all right,
that is a good friend of mine out here in London.
Says I am now on vacation and I'm going to laze about doing.
Fuck all.
Um,
and then that's it.
And then I come back to La and I'm going to get this fucking hour
yeah.
Of Shit.
A whipped into shape and maybe do another special,
I dunno.
I Dunno what I'm supposed to do in this new landscape of 15 minutes.
Specials,
hour specials.
Um,
well knows.
I got to figure out what the fucking next move is so I can keep coming over here
and uh,
having an unbelievable time.
Sorry if this podcast wasn't funny,
I'm still kind of floating from what happened last night.
Uh,
I still cannot believe I got to do that.
Um,
it's just,
yeah,
no words.
Speechless.
They actually had me sign the book,
you know,
and they like to you to sign the guestbook at Royal Albert after you did the
Gig.
And once again,
I can barely move.
I wrote something like that.
Just speechless.
You know,
I,
I don't know.
I didn't know what to say.
So it just said,
thanks.
Thanks for letting a fucking all shit and Dick Jokes over here.
Spend an hour and 15 minutes on that stage.
Can't fucking believe it.
Unbelievable.
All right.
That's it.
Enjoy the music.
And,
uh,
I'll talk to you when I'm in my fifties age.
All right,
here's a couple advertisements here.
Uh,
express VPN.
You know,
with all the news lately about data hacks and breaches,
data hacks and breaches,
sorry,
it's hard for me not to worry about my digital privacy.
Well,
there's an understatement no matter what you do online,
your prop,
your mobile carrier,
Internet service provide,
are tracking it all bastards,
Comcast,
Verizon,
Time Warner.
The list goes on these nosy bastards of trying to figure out what you're doing.
Companies like these have a record of every single thing you do.
Every website you visit,
every email you send,
it's ridiculous.
So that's why I decided to take my privacy back by using express VPN.
Is that what I did?
I wasn't aware of that these days.
I don't use the Internet without it.
I hate when they write copy like this.
I totally believe in this.
If this is what they're going to do.
How about that?
With Express Vpn,
your Internet data is encrypted and your IP address is hidden.
Express VPN costs less than seven bucks a month and it's rated the number one
VPN service by tech radar and dozens of expert reviewers.
Express VPN has easy to use.
APPS that run theme of earthly and the background of your computer,
phone and tablet turning on express VPN protection only takes a click no matter
what you do online,
whether you have something to hide is or you think you'd done that you don't
express VPN is for you.
Uh,
if you're on unsecured Wifi and wanting to keep hackers and spice from seeing
your data express VPN is for you,
well then just watch a bunch of slap fights and motorcycle videos with me and
the occasional porn.
And if you don't want providers like Verizon recording your entire online
history and then selling it to the whole world,
express VPN is for you to take back your Internet privacy today and find out how
you can get three months.
Go to express
vpn.com/bird that's express e x,
p r e s s v p n.com/pir for three months free with a one year package every day
you use the Internet without express VPN.
You're putting your sensitive information at risk.
Don't pull this off.
Don't put this off.
Sorry.
Protect your online data with express VPN today.
Visit Express vpn.com/ [inaudible] to learn mo.
All right,
next one here.
Postmates.
I use these guys as usual.
Your stomach and the rest of your life or it war.
Um,
you need to eat,
but you can't stop what you're doing to deal with it and not the only and the
only things wash and the only fast things that deliver are not what you want.
That means you don't want fast food.
Why don't these people realize I'm dumb?
Next,
please mention all the talk course.
I'm going to mention these.
Introducing Postmates,
the APP that adds a delivery.
Option two,
your favorite restaurants.
Imagine anything you want to eat delivered.
You don't have to drive,
park,
or even sit up.
They'll throw it right through the window.
You don't have to talk on a phone to order.
Just draw.
Download the APP and order 24 hours a day,
365 day,
24 hours a day.
Three 65 Postmates will bring you what you want within the hour.
God,
I need glasses.
You can see your f what?
You can see where your food is and track your driver.
It was kind of creepy.
You forgot to get eggs and milk.
No problem.
Craving a tasty burger.
Check looking for the perfect bottle of red wine or a summer beer.
Order up.
Postmates is your new longterm munchies booty call.
I want a little sideways for a limited time.
Postmate why don't we kill hooker?
We got ya.
For a limited time.
Postmates is giving you $100 of free delivery credit for your first seven days.
To start your free deliveries.
Download the APP today and use the Code Burr B U R R one zero zero that's
burned.
100 that's code borough 100 for $100 of free delivery credit for your first
seven days.
Save the hassle,
man.
Get the food you love fast.
At Postmates with the code burr 100 all right.
Lastly,
but not leastly hymns.
H I.
M.
S is that hairline slowly starting to move backwards,
would it?
How is this seven years ago?
Any bald spots yet?
Yeah,
all over my head.
How will you feel a year from now if you're,
if it's business as usual up there?
I asked you,
do you want a bald spot to pop up or do you want to do something about it first?
Do you realize how big a vat of whatever the hell this is?
They're gonna have to sell me.
Do you want your hairline to recede or do you want to do something about it
first?
Why do guys turned to weird solutions or do nothing?
What's called fucking being a man.
You,
I don't like other insult insulting me here.
Uh,
when they can turn to medicine and science
for hymns.com
I one stop shot shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual wellness for men,
thanks to science baldness can be optional.
Hims connects you with real doctors and medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss.
While I was never really a good looking fellow anyway,
so this is like putting mag wheels on a piece of shit.
But if you guys are good looking and this is a great product,
well known,
Jen,
a generic equivalents to name brand prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counters,
supplements,
prescription solution backed by science.
No waiting room,
no awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to four hymns.com answer a few quick questions.
Doctor will review and prescribe you products are shipped directly to your door.
My listeners,
my listeners,
get a trial month of hymns for just $5 today.
Right now while supplies last.
See the website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy,
go to hims.com/burr that's for him.
Sorry.
F O r a H.
I m s.com/burr for hims.com/bar one more time cause I said it the wrong way for
hymns
doc.
Slash.
Bar.
I got site subs right now.
I did a show in Dublin,
Ireland
and
all the crowds were great,
but I gotta tell you that those fucking people in Ireland as a funniest bit,
I can't even explain.
I swear it.
Well,
there's something about like when I go through Great Britain and Ireland,
it's like Scotland and Ireland.
They liked the knuckle heads that I grew up with.
And when I go to London,
London is like,
it's kind of like all the people that I met when I went to New York that were
from Boston.
So they,
they did move away from where they were from,
but they still brought that thing with them cause people in London are
hilarious.
But I was doing a show Dublin on Monday night at the,
the,
the vicar,
a vicar street theater or something.
Just this awesome venue.
And uh,
anyway,
so it was,
it was on a Monday night and it's a really hard night to try and sell tickets
and these people showed up in force.
Okay.
And I can't even tell you how
they were fucking hilarious.
Like I was on stage and there was this thing I was talking about about people
hugging their kids and how that could put is a good thing.
But if you do it too much,
it could potentially make a week or so.
I mentioned and all I've been telling this story for like six to eight months
and I've been saying how that,
you know,
my mother wasn't a hug,
hug her and didn't hug us when we were kids.
And people just listen and it's just a small detail that leads to this other
part that I want to talk about.
So I've said that line
uneventfully that's even a fucking word with no,
no issue whatsoever for like six months.
Now I'm in fucking Ireland and I just throw that line out there like I'm not
even thinking about it and say,
yeah.
I said,
you know,
my mother didn't hug me when I was a kid and I'm getting ready to say the next
sentence.
And like 15% of the crowd goes,
aw,
I'm not even doing it the way they did.
It just collectively broke my board.
It was just such the classic fucking,
it was like that Boston Irish thing that I grew up with distilled to its purest
form with actually real Irish people were
okay.
You'd almost have to be that a fucking understand what was behind it.
It was like I opened the emotional door,
just a crack in automatically.
It's just,
they just bust your balls about it.
Like,
ah,
you're fucking,
you know what I like?
And you think they,
I think we got hugs.
You freckled can't shut the fuck up and tell the judge I can't even,
it just,
I,
I've been trying to,
I would try to explain it to Nia.
She laughed,
but it's still,
yeah,
you kind of had to be there and then,
yeah.
You know,
so I laugh.
So when I'm a fucking trying to get your sympathy and trying to get to this
mess,
next part you assholes on the whole crowd.
Fucking laughs.
I see.
When I was growing up,
uh,
you know,
my mother never hugged us.
We didn't come from a family like that.
You know what I name
say?
This
island of no hugs.
I have your blood in me,
so don't fucking look at dam.
That's totally what that was.
Mom's did nagase a bucket.
What are you pitching a box?
You Pussy for the love of God.
Let me get through it.
Do you need any fucking countries?
I've said that in and nobody says shit.
An extra fun to try it and then we'll have a drink.
All the fucking Goddamn Mary.
Yes.
I guess you still have bullying but it continues on it.
And then like a half hour later,
what I had done when I was over there was I bought a bunch of DVDs with me.
Um,
like just the,
uh,
basically the DVD itself,
this little paper thing.
And I was just handing them out to people cause I'm trying to get them to show
other people,
you know,
when I'm out there so I can keep coming back.
Basically trying to get them to spread the word in my comedy.
And then someone's just like,
well why don't you just put it on Spotify?
You're dumb fucking,
I'm like,
yeah cause I'm old.
Alright.
I feel like I have to bring the hard copy.
So I tell these assholes,
then I've given them free DVDs at the end of the show
and I'm halfway through that spiel telling them that they're getting a free DVD.
All right?
And I'm in the middle of it and I hate this guy in the back.
That guy goes,
oh fuck off.
I don't even think I didn't even,
he explained what I was doing.
I don't know if I had gotten to the part where they were free.
I don't know what the fuck.
Always the fact that I was trying to once again go to a nice place where,
hey,
you know,
I really appreciate you guys coming out.
This really means a lot to me and I want to keep coming back here cause I think
he got a great comp country or whatever at night.
She's just opening the door that much.
Oh fuck off.
So I finally just looked at,
I went,
Jesus Christ,
they were already laughed and I was like,
you know what?
I played in 20 almost 22 years as a comedian.
I have played in front of some miserable motherfuckers but you guys and they
were already laughing are the most miserable fucking concert I've ever been in
and they loved it,
absolutely loved it.
And um,
it killed me that I couldn't go out drinking with the crowd cause they had a
fucking go a head,
an early flight of course,
all the way over to Helsinki.
Totally.
And I like I did,
I brought a bunch of Dvds and everything that complimentary.
If you guys coming up,
you said fuck off.
You don't want them
to take one.
[inaudible] like I drove into the back of your car.
[inaudible]
Huh?
I did the Kilkenny festival and Kilkenny Ireland and that one,
I don't remember Manet's on fries as much as I remember how many pints of
Guinness I drank and this we got hammered and this great laugh than I had with
dom.
I rarer,
me and dom were like,
we were just like,
we would like cliff and norm at chairs and just walking around that city and
everybody else would go to bed and we would still be like carousing right.
So one night we're walking up,
it's like fucking at probably two in the morning on like a Sunday night.
So,
you know,
sleepy town,
everybody's asleep.
We're walking up these cobblestones and the fucking moonlight.
Alright.
Like werewolves in London,
Shit.
It had rained so they would like the moonlight was glistening and we're walking
up and it's fucking quiet as hell on were drunk and were laughing but trying not
to,
you know,
wait for somebody to throw up in the shutters.
Right?
Hey Joe,
hey required here.
Right.
And we were walking up the thing and we're trying to find a bar that's still
open and all of a sudden we just heard these,
these,
you know,
these Irish singers.
Okay.
What time was this?
This was like two in the morning on a Sunday night.
So we just start following the sound of them singing,
come up please.
Cobblestones.
And then it sounds like the beginning of a great movie,
right?
Came up and become down.
We see the light on in this bar and we come walking in it.
By the time we get in,
um,
you know,
this guy was singing with two other people and they had gone up to the bar,
so it was only one guy singing when we came walking in and we come walking in
and it's just a bunch of townies sitting there way more seats than people.
Little empty,
but a small place.
And this guy's on stage just singing.
I got my,
my shake 80 82 80.
He's singing this fucking thing,
right?
And we're taking the bar and we look and there's this guy sitting right in front
of the stage and dude,
he was passed out at a level.
You'd never get this drunk in an American bar.
They'd send you home,
dude,
this guy,
he looks good.
This guy was completely passed.
I'll never forget,
he had one arm was slung over the back of the chair and then his head was just
hanging straight down.
When you're still behind him,
you couldn't see his head.
You just saw like his,
that this is next.
So the back of his neck and he was just sitting there hanging in there.
It looked like he had gotten shot and we walked in and nobody was really talking
and this is guys slumped over and all we hear is it and everybody turns around
and looks at us.
And meanwhile that guy's in the background going,
Eh,
green alligator,
long neck,
goose show,
whatever.
And he fucking look at each other.
And it was like one of those things where we now we can't leave.
So we are,
we walk up to the bar and they ask,
you know,
really thick Irish brogue what we want in order to a couple of genesis.
And I'm sitting there trying to hold it the other,
cause I know I can't look at dom and I'm hearing dom starting to laugh and this
guy is still singing and dom starts,
dom starts riffing,
he starts riffing lyrics to what this guy singing and he's just in my ear going,
I get,
I shuffled [inaudible] and he's to this thing and do it.
We started,
we started fucking laughing and we couldn't stop like to school goes and the
whole thing was what was keeping it going was if there's tension like in like in
high school or Middle School when the teacher goes to the next personal left,
yeah.
Gets fucking detention.
Like that tension makes you,
you can't stop fucking no,
no.
Yeah.
So we knew they were looking at it and I'm getting nervous.
Like I,
they think we're laughing at their country and all this.
So I'm trying to be polite and not laugh at all.
It just,
it just do it.
It was this fucking wave of laughing.
I remember,
I've never seen dom like I was looking at,
he literally like,
his mouth was open and he had tears.
It,
it,
and then what was cracking me up was it looked like almost like he was crying
and that what that guy was singing was making me cry.
So then there was another wave of laughs,
oh my God,
the guy's just slunched over and,
and the whole time.
And then like the bartender would look at me like,
what the fuck are you laughing at?
And I would look over,
look away and all I could look at with this guy slumped over and it's this guy
on stage and he was singing,
he had his eyebrows up and he was hitting these fucking high notes and do it
was,
it was torture,
but it was a great laugh.
But it was that whole thing probably took all of four minutes.
But like Mike,
Mike,
my stomach was fucking killing me.
Oh my God.
I would have loved to see the,
I would have loved to somewhere in those adventures.
I think
I picked up.
Oh,
that's a great story.
That's fine.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burns the Monday morning podcast for June 7th,
2010 how the hell are you?
What's going?
Are you get better?
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
I can't get away from that fucking oil spill.
No.
Try to go out to a bar.
You try to drink your troubles away.
And every time I look up to some fucking burger getting picked up
by scientist,
you know,
I like,
I wouldn't,
you know,
when they pick up the bird,
they still have to make sure that the bird doesn't like fucking bite.
The shit out of him still was picking up a Pelican,
you know?
And he's got his,
he's got his gardener glove and he's holding the beak shut.
He's fucking stupid animals.
It's like,
dude,
I'm trying to help you.
You know,
I can't help you if you don't want help.
you dumb fuck,
look at me.
The one at each show.
Would I be gingerly picking you up?
Why are you trying to bite me?
That shit you're covered in his oil.
All you dumb.
Fuck.
If you weren't such a stupid bird,
you,
you'd understand the gas combustion engine,
you know?
Um.
Anyways,
whatever.
Blaming the victim here is fucking unreal,
man.
Can they just kept that shit?
All right.
You know,
I'll Dama my dual can it,
can,
they just can't.
They just put a top on it,
you know,
for the first time I actually looked at the spill.
There's certain things that I just can't watch.
The second I heard what was going on down there,
it's like I'm not going to watch that shit because I have absolutely no power
to,
to stop it.
All I can do is just sit there watching it going,
fuck,
you know,
whatever.
What are you gonna do?
What do you,
what the fuck?
How the fuck do you stop it
once the blue spoon.
I'm,
I'm Kinda handicapped this week.
People as I had a crazy fucking weekend and uh,
my brother is still sleeping in the other room,
so this is going to be one of those,
um,
medium energy podcast of fuck you all right.
Fuck you.
Who have just side whoever just rolled your fucking eyes,
right?
You don't have a medium energy day.
Well,
you don't put in the fucking effort.
You know,
like what's his face that power forward for the fucking Lakers,
who's full of gummy bears and every other fucking game is sugar crashes and he's
not worth a shit.
How are we sick?
His name is not Lamar Odom.
I always think it's Riley Odom who I believe was a guy who played for the
fucking Broncos,
Riley old hymns and the 70s what was it?
Haven Moses.
I Dunno.
I Dunno where these names come through,
but I'm sick.
You know everybody fucking talking about the God damn oil spill.
You know,
acting like human beings are the fucking worst.
Went down there and we're trying to help these filthy animals in and in,
in the effort to help them.
This does still attacking us.
Okay.
You know,
it's like,
dude,
I can't help you.
You know,
you have to want help.
Okay,
you got it.
You got to want to change.
You got to want to come out of the Muck,
dude.
All right.
I got to fucking pull you onto this sludge and cover your mouth at the same
fucking time.
What it was this,
some sort of Jujitsu,
some animal Jujitsu.
Oh,
Jesus.
Morning Sweetheart.
Yeah.
What was with little,
yeah,
okay.
You know,
some days when your significant other walks by a you just now this is one of
these days,
you know,
those couple of points that I want to make in the relationship.
I'll wait till tomorrow to try and make those points.
Whew.
Jesus Christ.
She looked like a fucking future hall of fame quarterback in the twilight of her
career in the morning.
You know,
that's how she,
when she walked by Jesus Christ,
that was such a great fucking reference.
And I butchered it.
She looked like a future hall of Famer in the twilight.
I th I think I did it backwards.
What MCV?
Paula pit pitbulls tail.
He liked that Cleo.
You're like,
I don't pull it.
I just hold onto it.
All right.
Get out of my face.
Look at you.
You're not covered in oil.
Would you try to bite me if I pulled you out?
You wouldn't,
you'd be sitting there going,
oh,
all right.
So anyways,
um,
speaking of the Lakers and Celtics,
it's just,
just a fucking insane time of the year with the NBA finals and the Nhl finals
are on at the same time.
You know,
and women just go crazy cause they loving it.
They love and every second of the sports,
my girl watches every fucking TV show then involves let's take the dumbest
comment from the stupidest state and uh,
just start documenting their family,
you know,
and then that,
then the people start ramping up the stupid because the cameras are on.
I went in there,
she was watching something.
They had just a bunch of dumb skanks from Jersey planning a fucking wedding in
rather than addressing the real issue,
which is that these people are gonna fucking procreate.
They're actually dealing with this little shit about,
oh my God,
I wanna wear Chiffon
and all my skanky bridesmaids,
you know,
with their scraped out uteruses from all those abortions have to wear the same
fucking color.
I mean that's television people.
I don't think it is.
It's not television.
How do we go from Lawrence Welk to that number?
When we had family values,
Lawrence Welk had so many morals.
It was actually creepy hub on then to two,
go on youtube and go look up the Lawrence Welk show.
There was a dance team on there.
Bobby and Susie or something.
Just the widest,
purest.
Um,
let's go spoon with Jesus.
Fucking white names you could ever come up with.
And they used to do these.
They used to fucking dance these stupid smiles on their face and it was just
that classic little skippy dues.
Skippy do all across the fucking
the fucking stupid dance floor,
you know?
You know they both had fucking eating disorders.
God goddamn dancers.
You've got to have the body of a fucking seventh grade or your entire life.
It's like if 35 years old,
what do you eat?
Huh?
Fucking handful of cottage cheese before you go out the God damn door.
Cleo,
get up.
Get away from me.
Come on.
You sniff it up my feet.
I'm trying to focus here.
Okay.
Dogs are so fucking emotional.
Look at that.
Look on your face.
You really just had a sad look on your face.
Now you're making me feel bad.
Hmm.
Anyways,
talking about the Lawrence Welk show.
Go look that shit up.
It was just,
it was just,
it was fucking horrible.
Some of those shows back then,
you know,
that's,
that's kind of like what I grew up on.
Ya know,
I just saw those shows and I sat down and watched it for the longest time.
That was like music to me,
you know,
and I asked for,
uh,
I want to record,
I want to,
I wanted some music for my birthday at the,
I don't even know what,
I didn't know what it was.
I just wanted to record,
give me a record.
And the first record I was given was a sing along with Mitch and the gang.
It was a Mitch Miller record.
You know,
I always wondered why I never got laid in high school.
But you know,
when,
when you're,
when you're weaned on roll out the barrel,
oh,
he's other kids at singing like fucking Aerosmith and led Zeppelin.
And I'm like,
won't you come Home Bill Bailey,
won't you come home?
You love her.
Whoa.
You know what kind of kid and the third grade wants to play the Banjo.
I didn't know any better.
I didn't know that there was electric guitar.
I actually liked it to book fucking Mickey Finn.
Huh?
The fucking something.
Or Robert E.
Lee.
That was like one of my favorite song.
Ted Heath Orchestra Elks parade.
Those are my jams.
I used to sit there and you know,
normal kids would sit there and they'll listen to like some fucking
yeah.
You know,
classic rock and then fantasize about being able to play it.
First of all,
the fucking hot broads in their 14th fifth,
fourth grade class,
you know,
normal fantasies.
I was actually thinking about playing the trumpet Solo on one o'clock jump
that'll get on bill that have them all lined up,
you know,
the extra saliva mouths with their fucking braces.
I always loved that when kids got braces.
I lucked out.
I never had to have braces.
Kids had braces and like the,
they'll give body thinking it's food for the first fucking two weeks trying to
break it down.
Very shakable um,
ah,
fucking elastic bands.
What are these fucking pussy kids have nowadays where they got that?
He got that clear channel Shit they put in there.
Whatever the fuck it is.
The clear I was at the fucking stuff the athletes take
mmm.
At a fucking what the fuck is.
And you know that that shit where
it's just a plastic mouth guard you put in your mouth and you don't have to go
through the torture.
The kids,
you know,
from my grade had to go through this is like,
really,
that's like old school standup material,
you know,
having to go there and get your fucking braces tightened.
You know,
right now,
Mike,
Mike.
I ain't [inaudible] on my computer screen.
Went to um,
the save mode and what it does is it,
it,
it puts up all the albums that I've downloaded onto my douchey fucking iPod,
which sucks,
which breaks every six months or needs to be updated because he can't handle the
new technology.
I have an,
I have a nice mix of music here,
Gordon Lightfoot.
Oh,
this is some easy listening to shit.
Sting.
God smacked.
Let me try to get some credibility.
Houses of the holy,
one of the worst lead's up on albums ever except for two songs.
The rain song and fucking no quarter,
the crunch is,
I am going to elect is one of the worst songs ever written by a great band.
MMM.
Oh,
Stevie wonder,
what does that one songs in the key of a odd,
is it Jay z one?
I don't know why I have that.
Which one is that one?
Is that the one where he was going to retire,
but then he didn't lamb of God.
The Romantics.
Remember that one?
What I like about you,
when they had the red suits on red leather suits and there was nothing wrong
with it.
I'm at one with Justin Timberlake steps on the crystal ball,
the disco ball,
cause he was bringing sexy back.
Remember that?
Wham,
wham,
um,
Neil young harvest moon,
Merle.
Travis,
look at me.
I'm all over the fucking map.
1950s hits and highlights the nerves.
Any this best of brick.
Okay.
Jeff Beck truth that album.
Huh?
Remember that one that had half a led Zeppelin one Chaco Pastoria
audio slave.
It's a super group.
Okay,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
I started to talk about Lakers,
Celtics,
and,
uh,
I'm gonna extend an olive branch right now and rather than doing the usual and
going off and that type of shit,
I want,
I want to,
you know what?
I'm even going to drag in the hockey fans too.
I want to talk right now to fans or the Celtics,
the Lakers,
the Black Hawks and the flyers because,
uh,
I,
I got a question because I'm having a fucking heart attack.
I'm aging like seven years,
which eat with each point that is scored or not scored in a,
the Celtics Lakers series.
And a,
I going to ask you,
you big sports fans out there.
Why do we give a fuck?
Okay.
You know what?
It's,
it's fucking stupid.
I get it.
I get,
I mean,
you know,
you were this,
I give a fuck so much than I'm actually jealous of people who don't give a shit.
Like last night after I watched the game,
like,
you know,
I felt like I got,
I got acquitted or something.
Like that's the level of stress.
I'm just sitting there,
you know,
like fucking r Kelly thinking there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Holy Shit.
They had video.
It looks just like you.
I know,
but it's not me.
You know?
All those years it'd be offended when everybody says we all look alike.
Now I'm saying we all look alike because I peed on a 12 year old amongst other
things.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
why do we give a fuck to that law?
Like I'm sitting there like,
this is,
this is how much I give a shit.
I know you guys are going to think this is nuts.
I actually had an opportunity to,
somebody at the last second had a ticket to the game.
It's a 20 minute fucking ride down the street and I turned it down.
I turned it down because I,
first of all,
I already went to an NBA finals game.
I already went,
okay,
so I checked that off the bucket list.
I went to the Lakers,
Celtics actually lost Lakers,
Celtics final.
You don't.
If you're going to go to a final game,
that's the great thing.
And I went into enemy territory with my fucking Celtic shirt on and I basically
paid like 400 bucks or whatever the fuck to sit in the last row of the staple
center to every five seconds to have somebody go sale takes our beaches.
You know,
I,
it's like I paid to get verbally fucking abused and to not hear the commentating
and all that type of shit,
but it was still awesome to be there.
But,
um,
I,
it's like I give a fuck too much.
I want to hear the God damn game.
I don't want to sit there and have to look around fat fucks and drunks getting
up to get their goddamn beer and listen to their stupid shit.
I know it's,
it's not worth it.
I'm paying money to be tortured.
I don't want to do it.
So I actually stayed in my living room
and I watched the game on mute.
I can't even listen to the fucking announcers cause they drive me nuts.
And half of it is because sometimes they say dumb shit.
And the other half is because I'm so psychotically into my team that I am
convinced that everyone in the booth hates my team,
secretly hates my fucking team.
I actually have a debate with Paul Versey comedian,
right?
Dude,
who opens up for me.
You people in New York on the east coast,
you've seen them don't act like you haven't,
um,
or even down in Atlanta.
Oh yeah.
The dude,
I don't name names,
he may or may not have been the guy I went to fucking the master's with in bed
on the turtles.
But anyways,
um,
he's convinced that Tim McCarver hates the fucking Yankees and I'm like,
dude,
he hates the fucking red sox.
And then we just kind of came to a conclusion that,
uh,
you know,
it's kind of in our head and also the Tim McCarver might kind of be a Douche a
little bit.
I think he likes the cardinals because that's who we played for.
But whatever,
I'm getting off track like that.
Don't you wish,
do you have a wishlist?
Sometimes you didn't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Like after I did my show and went down.
I mean,
actually after I watched the Lakers game,
I went down the street and,
uh,
I did stand up and a,
I came walking in and I was talking to some dude who was from New Hampshire.
So I'm like,
oh,
Celtics,
right?
And he's like,
yeah,
yeah.
He goes,
they win tonight.
And I'm like,
you fucking Dick.
You fucking,
yeah,
they won.
Yeah,
they want.
Okay.
So now you get to have the joy that they won and you didn't have to go through
the fucking cardiac arrest that I went through.
Oh,
it's unreal.
When the Lakers stock coming back,
I got to walk out of the fucking room.
Literally,
I walk out of the room,
come back in,
I peek,
peek back into the fucking my can't fucking take it.
It's like the oil spill.
It's like this fucking thing that I want to turn out.
Right.
And,
and it isn't,
and there's nothing I can fucking do about it.
I'm just sitting there fucking helpless,
you know?
I don't know what I gotta do.
I gotta I gotta be on like a fucking stair master,
like some broad will.
I watch it to get that extra energy out.
I fucking like every like seven minutes.
I'll take the mute button off and I can listen to a sentence and a half before
van Gundy or somebody else.
All these,
these fucking guys who played the game,
coached the game,
know way more about the game and I am immediately convinced that they don't know
what the fuck they're talking about.
And I start yelling at my TV like a God damn maniac.
I'll tell you what else fucking sucks.
That's right.
I'm on a roll here about shit that sucks fucking,
I lived in New York,
like I'm so fucking sick of living in the city that is the arch rival of the,
of one of my teams,
you know,
and all day long I got to look at these fucking Laker flags flapping off the
side of the cars.
You know those things.
A Gay,
by the way,
you drive down the streets with,
you flew
with your fucking team flags in the window.
You seen those little clip on.
Thanks.
Actually I see them and I start,
I start getting angry.
You know what I mean?
Like it's a fucking alcaide a flag.
Do they have a flag?
You know,
what is,
what does it have them a sneak it into a pizza parlor,
crouching in a cave
fucking punks.
Um,
I just,
I,
I see them and I just want to fucking,
uh,
you know,
I don't know for some reason,
like,
like wire cutters.
I don't know why you'd need wire cutters to cut a plastic poor excuse for a
flagpole.
I just want to snip them off
when we went.
What did we really bill,
you take it to that level.
Yeah.
I,
okay.
I don't do it,
but like,
I want to,
I would've gone to that Laker game,
uh,
yesterday and I would've fantasized about beating the shit out of everybody in
my row,
you know,
and the Celtics winning by 40.
It's not healthy.
It's not fucking healthy.
Look at my leg,
my legs fucking shaking right now.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing here.
So,
yeah.
So basically I lived,
I lived in New York during the height of the curse of the baby.
Every time I wanted to go see the red sox,
I had to sit and fucking Yankee stadium had people go 1918 you know,
and I got that Catholic fucking,
you know,
punish me shit.
So I'd show up with my red sox shit on,
you know.
And at that point we hadn't won in 86 years.
So all I could do was just personally attack the looks of the person,
you know,
make fun out of their hat,
looks stupid on their head or some shit like that.
And they would be like,
well what,
what does your have to do with championships?
Nothing.
You fucking idiot.
We haven't won in [inaudible] 86 years.
I got nothing here.
All you can talk about is how you,
how,
how neatly your man tits sit on your fucking,
your beer belly.
I Dunno.
So then whatever the red sox finally won and I can breathe,
you know,
what song is that?
I can breathe again,
can breathe again.
One of those fucking 80 songs he thought really meant something
down and down and down and have now
the fuck was it.
I was a lot of reverb.
Reverb makes up for a lot.
That's like the poor man's fucking autotune.
Um,
anyways,
fuck am I talking about here?
Yeah.
So then that shit ends,
you know,
Celtics,
a dead in the fucking water then I,
they're technically not even a fucking NBA team.
When,
when I make the decision to move out here and I move out here,
you don't want the most underhanded deals in the history of sport.
Kevin Mchale somehow dissolve.
We'll give you our best player for nobody.
Give it back to our form of fucking team that I used to play for.
And next thing you know where the shit,
and then I got a sale takes at Bhs and I gotta listen to them fucking these
fucking flags.
They hate it.
Why can't this business being like,
you know,
Oregon,
this is how much I fucking hate.
Like I'm sitting there watching the game,
right?
And all of a sudden I see Hillary Swank,
you know,
court side,
the worst court side,
and all of fucking basketball is the fucking Lakers.
Jesus Christ,
those people with their fucking laminated faces.
This is how fucking fucked up people are out here in la.
They get plastic surgery in their twenties.
It's like you,
you Outta your mind,
you debts.
Take a picture yourself in your 20s.
When you get to your 50s,
then hand him the picture and be like,
I want to look like that.
You know,
give them something to work off of.
Give these guys 30 years to fuck up other people's faces before they get to
yours.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
stop eating fried food.
Get on a fucking treadmill.
What's wrong with you?
Right?
I'm telling you for coming,
you know,
game six,
like I'm going to go,
yeah,
if it,
if,
if there is a good six,
this is going to be a game six.
This is going to be a torturous fucking series.
Um,
I am worried about the Celtics Garnette his heart and Paul Pierce,
it hurt their fucking,
uh,
the van Gundy's go their car nuts only gone up with one hand.
That's all I heard.
We got to use two hands for a rebound.
I hit fucking mute.
I'm like,
you think he doesn't fucking know that?
And then my buddy Paul verse,
he calls up,
he goes,
dude,
I think Garnett's heart.
He kept rubbing his shoulder,
right?
And then all of a sudden my buddy called me today.
He goes,
yeah,
the saying that on the radio,
he fucked up his shoulder.
See,
that's why I don't listen.
Put It on fucking mute.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't like how just all these fucking people will now act like,
like the same way the Lakers won the first game,
then all of a sudden other Celtics fucking fished.
Right.
And now the Celtics won.
Now who the Lakers foot can be good.
Do they play two games?
It's one,
one.
It's a great fucking series so far.
Okay.
It's the usual fucking thing.
They always got to act like whatever just happened.
His law for the rest of the rest of fucking time.
I can't,
I it,
it drives me fucking nuts.
But I gotta tell you this dude,
I owe a IOP Alga Saul and apology.
All right.
Now I'm not going to be a dick here and be like,
well,
you know,
Garnette is in fucking 100% whatever.
That guy's going strong to the fucking hoop.
He is not the guy he was a two fucking years ago.
That guy playing fucking great.
That fucking baseline reverse jam he had was the shit was the shit.
You see this,
this is a Celtics fan given pau Gasol props in the middle of the fucking series.
And I wish more you fucking sport cunts could act like that instead of fucking,
you know,
latch and you're hitching up the trailer of your loser life up to your fucking
team to the point.
So you get so into it that you can't even,
you can't even appreciate it.
A fucking good play.
You know,
he's fucking red sox fans who fucked Derek Jeter.
Really,
really
fucking stupid.
You know,
guys,
the Shit fucking,
you know of the best players I've ever fucking seen.
You know,
the way he handles his shit on and off,
you know,
do I want the guy that went,
fuck no,
but am I going to sit here like an asshole,
you know,
and act like this dude isn't a great player or that fucking reverse jam.
Pau Gasol head was the shit.
I want to know how Pollock is.
Saul became a Laker.
He's a fucked up looking white dude.
If that doesn't say Celtic,
I don't know what does.
And this is really like the classic Celtics Lakers series where they've always
been just,
you know,
faster,
always had more talent and we've always just been,
you know,
like this,
this fucking,
you know,
fucking fucked up look and team.
But somehow we win.
How many good looking Celtics have there,
Ben?
I mean this
Larry Bird,
Dennis Johnson,
Kevin Mchale,
Kevin Mchale I guess had dreamy eyes if you're just focused on that,
but the rest of his body,
good Lord.
He looks like his fucking arms are so God damn long.
He looks like he would walk like that thing in the and,
and uh,
what was that movie with the CIC crawled up out of the,
well,
was that the movie?
Oh is it that other movie that the,
the uh,
oh Jesus Christ.
One of those Japanese horror movies with that fucking thing crawls.
And as it moves its hands,
its back legs would step over its front fucking legs,
like some sort of mute and crab.
I Dunno,
I don't fucking know.
Kendrick Perkins.
I saw Kendrick Perkins,
by the way,
a lobby of this hotel about a week ago.
That guy is a fucking mountain of a man.
He's a fucking mountain,
you know,
and to think that he looks like medium size next to Shaq,
these fucking people that ate.
Oh,
if you ever get down on yourself that you never made,
you never made it to the professional ever stand next to a professional athlete
and just realize that it was game over by third grade when there's people
walking around with that sort of fucking bionic DNA.
Jesus Christ.
I can't believe I was allowed to go to gym class.
Pass the fucking sixth grade,
my pasty fucking Forrest Gump legs.
Um,
anyways,
so let's get back to this shit man.
Why of why,
you know,
maybe,
maybe you guys can just answer me that.
Why the fuck do we care so much?
Like right now,
you know who's getting their God damn fucking heart's ripped out and our aging
of the fans of the Black Hawks in the flyers.
All right.
This,
this is one of these great series where somebody is finally going to have that
Advil lifted off their chest.
Blackhawks have a 1 cents 61 the flyers have a 1 cents 75.
Okay?
75 isn't as bad as 61.
But you know what the fuck?
You know,
I was writing on my Facebook page.
We pulled out of Vietnam in 1975.
All right?
There was only one kind of cheerios in 1975.
You understand?
I've got a deadline.
Am I putting
this in historical perspective here and can I dumb it down to the Rubik's cube
was still about six,
seven years away.
People the last time the flyers want it.
Okay,
lovely.
You just got gotta fucking dumb everything down.
Um,
friend of mine who actually runs the,
uh,
the m m podcast page,
the uh,
the fan page,
the official and only fan page or the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
who you get some exclusive.
Okay.
Uh,
whatever you know what to do is I do the podcast now cause I want,
I,
I want to take this podcast and next level is what I do is I do the podcast
then.
Aye.
You know,
I upload it and I sent it to the dude who runs that page and he puts all the
fucking,
you know,
all the references up,
all the youtube videos and everything.
Then we try to sync it where we,
we both fucking put it on at the same time,
you know,
taking it to the next level.
Okay.
Totally lost.
Just lost my fucking train of thought here.
Um,
oh,
that's right.
He sent me this article.
This is the classic,
just dumb and down just pussy way that we're running this country right now.
These stairs,
p people actually,
I guess the,
uh,
the nationwide,
the national spelling bee is coming up,
you know,
and everybody laughs at these,
these kids who go up there,
they're right at their fucking awkward years,
you know what I mean,
where they have the nose of the adult and like the fucking teeth of a fucking
two year old,
you know,
12 year old.
So,
um,
they have haven't the national spelling bee and Washington DC,
they celebrate these,
uh,
these brainiac fucking kids that eventually will work for a corporation.
And without really knowing it will probably work on some device that'll Sunday
kill millions of people,
you know,
in other words,
the future.
So there's people actually they're picketing,
dispelling B.
All right.
I had to,
I had to fucking read this to actually believe it.
Okay.
It says,
not all s spellers headed for Washington DC for the National Spelling Bee,
spelling bee on June 1st through the third think English spelling is a good
thing that should be celebrated with spectators and judges inside the Grand
Hyatt Hotel,
uh,
awhile while spectators and judges inside the Grand Hyatt Hotel will be
pondering the spellings of obscure words and admiring the efforts of contestants
outside on the street.
Some members of the American Literacy Council and the Simplified Spelling
Society,
Aka the s s s we'll be trying to convince Passerbuys that the English spelling
is a problem that needs fixing.
Yeah.
Why are people so fucking dumb?
Okay.
And now that's something.
If you want to get support,
simplified spelling society,
you don't go to the fucking nationwide spelling bee where the,
the kids just learned,
okay,
how to spell fucking rheumatoid arthritis.
So whenever the fuck they're going to ask him,
can you use an authentic,
your grandmother has rheumatoid arthritis.
Okay.
That was mean.
Ah,
rheumatoid arthritis.
Isn't that two words?
Um,
why won't you just go to a bar?
Okay.
You want to get names on that fucking petition.
That's who you're doing it for.
The dumb fucks.
This is the point these people have it said like those insides side,
they may admire the efforts of the contestants,
but they will have signs and sandwich boards with slogans such as I'm through
with,
through.
Okay.
In other words,
t,
H,
r,U ,
and t.
I'm through with,
through and enough is enough spelled e.
and enough is too much spelled e.
Their aim is to alert parents,
educators,
politicians,
business people and others concerned about the unacceptable level of illiteracy,
illiteracy among English speakers to the fact that a prime cause for this is
English spelling.
Do you get it?
The reason why there's such a high level of illiteracy is not because we
constantly cut funding to the public schools,
not because spelling is something that's even fucking stressed by most people
anymore.
It's because the words are too difficult to spell.
One of the pickers pickers,
one of the picketers.
This is hilarious and I can't even fucking read.
I'm part of the problem.
I might sign these people's petition.
Um,
one of the picketers at the ALC chair and the SSS member,
Allen Mole from Boulder,
Colorado,
put it this way,
are odd spelling retains words like cough bowl through and though this increases
illiteracy and crime fix it and you fix a host of problems,
we want to fix it to this guy is basically saying
that the reason why there's serial killers,
there's people holding up fucking Mcdonald's,
there's purse snatchers,
okay.
And all this type of shit is because cat is not spelled with a k,
you know,
I mean on once side.
I fucking respect this guy because he's actually has a cause.
He actually got off his couch and said,
you know what?
I'm going to do something about this.
This is the reverse of what I was trying.
Maybe that's why.
Let's get smart America bombed on my podcast.
You know,
you guys,
we'll wait for this sss guy to come in here.
You know,
I mean not,
not to be the classic person who goes,
what's going to happen next,
but what is going to happen next?
Two plus two was like four or five,
three,
you know,
as long as you within one,
we'll give it to you.
Rounded off to the nearest right answer.
Learn how to fucking spell your lazy fucks as pathetic.
And I also like how to like the illiteracy illiteracy problem is,
you know,
that's the reason why this fucking crime,
law.
I bet those fucking bankers,
you know,
those bankers are literate and they're great at math.
They're great at fucking math where it always works out for them.
The fucking cunts.
They went till fucking Ivy League schools.
Why did I,
why did I take her off?
I believe schools,
Ivy League schools,
they went to Ivy League fucking schools and went to Brown.
They went to Cornell.
Wentworth.
I Dunno,
that's one for you that,
that did some party fucking,
uh,
you know,
something that's,
you know what killed it?
What killed it was a was cable.
That's what,
that's what,
that's what really made people dump cable and the Internet.
800 fucking channels.
You know,
people used to,
back in the day,
they used to load up a something called a station wagon.
All right.
First of all,
everybody had like five fucking kids back in the day.
All right.
Which was a great thing to do.
You know,
cause you know a couple of them are going to be fuck ups.
Okay.
And you can let it go.
You can let it go.
That's why parents who have only one kid is so fucking over protective,
but peck protective is because they went all in world series of poker.
They pushed all the chips and this is their one fucking hope.
That kid can't be a fucking serial killer.
You have seven,
eight fucking kids.
You know one of them,
you know
you can handle it.
You can fucking handle it.
If one of them's a phase,
the black sheep,
what are you going to do?
You know,
what the fuck are you going to do?
I mean the guy,
he's a
transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac.
Huh?
Anybody remember that line there?
He met a transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac the greatest line ever uttered on
the fucking a and e channel,
possibly in television history when they were talking about these ds,
this,
this serial killer tandem.
That's how they described one of the guys.
One of the guys was just killing somebody on his own and then he had to leave
town
because the heat was getting too high and he went to a new town,
hangs out in some shady bar,
and that's where he meets his,
his,
his serial killer partner.
You know,
Kinda like what Bill Gates met that other fucking nerd.
And they made the first laptop.
These two serial killers came together
and to describe his partner that the fucking,
that Bill Curtis guy goes there.
He met a transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac
back in the day people we had station wagons and there was a whole bunch of
fucking kid.
He didn't have to have a fucking spelling bee.
Okay,
you have a spelling bee because you only have one kid and the kid can't compete
against himself.
You've got to go with a bunch of other fucking kids.
Back in the day we had station wagons and they were full of fucking kids.
All right.
And you just,
you drove somewhere and on the way there,
you know,
you listen to Mitch Miller.
Okay.
Bullies [inaudible] room,
right?
And you fucking,
you said Shit like,
um,
do you get your,
your parents would quiz you.
What are Ivy League schools named the capitols of states,
you know,
that's what the fuck you did.
And you stopped at a rest area.
Your Dad sent you in there by yourself.
There was no problem,
there was no worries.
And you walked in there and some guy exposes himself to you it or not a deal
with it.
It just buried it.
You got back in the fucking car and next thing you know you're at a dairy queen,
sort of enjoying the ice cream,
but sorta not.
That's when America was intelligent back when we used to have like five,
six kids and you throw him in a fucking station wagon and then you quizzed him
and as you drove to some poor excuse for a tourist attraction,
you know,
you go out to go look at fucking while build Cody's fucking log cabin.
You know,
your dad be sitting there seething with anger,
left arm,
all sunburned from having it hanging out the side fucking window.
The rest of them ghost white.
Now,
was it spelling tests,
quizzes and dairy queen.
Somewhere along the line it became OMG laughing my fucking ass off all this
abbreviation.
These people want to turn it into that.
Fuck that man up.
You pussies learn how to spell God damn words.
I did it for a month.
I'm a better speller because it because of it.
Because it I'm not,
I've already forgot.
I finally conquered the word restaurant though forever.
I couldn't remember whether you went.
It's rest.
And then a U.
R a.
N.
T.
I could never remember if the you came,
which,
which a,
the,
you came after.
Is it restaurant or restaurant?
Gretar aunt.
It's a restaurant.
These fucking people would spell it.
T restaurant now.
Oh,
that was still be fucked up.
How do you spell rant?
Dose.
Yeah.
You know that's restaurant.
How do I spell that?
Phonetically?
Okay.
Restaurant.
Let's go to the fucking restaurant.
I look,
I'm getting so worked up like these guys are actually going to succeed.
Um,
you know,
it's like listen to the people down the south when they talk about the south
Gilda rise again.
Is it,
are you going to secede from the union?
How did that work up the first time?
Um,
wow.
Look at me.
What is wrong with me?
All right,
let's get to some youtube videos for the fucking week.
Um,
for the fucking week.
Listen to me with my tough talk.
Um,
all right,
hang on a second.
I've got a couple actually really good a drum videos for you guys to watch.
They're actually hilarious.
Somebody sent me this on my uh,
on my Facebook and the name of this video is this drummer search.
This,
this drummer is at the wrong gig.
Okay.
And it's just a guy where he is fucking,
this guy is awesome.
He is performing like it's still 1986 and they are opening for like fucking
motley crew and he is trying to blow Tommy Lee off the stage.
That's the way he is performing.
And they are,
they're playing at like just some fucking banquet and everybody else has,
I'm playing at a banquet energy and this motherfucker is just like,
I don't know.
I've played drums for fucking years and I would have to slow the video down to
try and figure out how the fuck he's doing some of this shit.
Okay.
He does this move with his both his arms.
He looks like he's in a dryer.
It's the only way to describe it is fucking code is flying around is somehow he
never misses a beat.
It's fucking awesome.
But it looks absolutely ridiculous yet.
Awesome.
Yeah,
just check it out.
All right.
And you can watch all these videos if you don't want to search.
Okay.
I'll make it easy for you.
Just like the SSS people go to the,
uh,
the man podcast.com and uh,
we'll have all that shit update for you.
Here's another one.
Korean drummer rocks out.
This is actually from a long time ago,
but this guy is just fucking,
you know,
it's just what,
what drumming and performing is all about this guy.
He's the shit.
A lot of times people,
I'm the drummer I'm sitting by and all these drums,
no one's going to look at me,
this fucking guy,
you can't not look at them.
And they got this hot girl sing in the song,
you know,
and he's fucking,
he's starts headbanging and these,
I think this,
this guy's like headbanging before people knew how to head bang,
um,
in is the last thing.
Uh,
you can go on youtube and na checkout because I tried to download this album.
It's the first Arrow Smith album,
which I haven't listened to I think in about 15 years.
It's such a great album.
It's the one that dream on was initially on that's only like the really the real
head off it.
And they usually play like mama kin and stuff in concert,
but they're,
it,
they're,
they're so fucking,
the album is so like raw and Steven Tyler's voice,
he sounds so young and he's just,
he's right at the beginning of like a few of like his signature ways of like
phrasing and stuff.
And uh,
it's just a fucking killer album.
And my favorite song on it is a song called moving out by Aerosmith and,
uh,
it's great.
They'll just,
the production of it and everything,
it's just so fucking like,
it just sounded like they scrape their last couple of fucking dimes together and
put it out.
Um,
and I'm actually going to go to a fucking,
I'm going to go to Amoeba records today.
I'm going to fucking buy that album because,
uh,
I tried to download it on iTunes and they don't have it.
Isn't that a surprise?
Isn't that a fucking surprise?
Um,
I don't know who to blame on that one.
Is it Aerosmith?
Cause they're like,
well,
I don't like the production of that.
Or we have,
you know,
our two hits,
I was on like 47 different ever other compilations.
I don't know what,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm right now,
I'm gonna put some money in those fuckers pockets,
download that whole album,
go out and buy.
It's the shit.
They'd just a shit.
All right,
so where are we at here?
42 minutes in almost 43 minutes and I got to cover another fucking seven
minutes.
And then I can fucking
can upload this fucking thing and get on with my God damn day here.
Uh Oh.
By the way,
I'm going to be a Caroline's comedy club this week with a Paul Versey opening up
and in the middle,
young Joe to Rosa,
the teen idol sensation from the opiate Anthony show.
I know a lot of you out there read teen beat,
so you're all up on Joe and his latest hairstyle,
but a,
for those of you not familiar with Joe,
he has,
he has a wonderful spread coming out in a next next month,
uh,
teen beat anniversary issue where he's,
you know,
he's,
he's swinging on a tire,
you know,
shirtless laying in a field,
very,
uh,
very Keith Partridge,
Shaun Cassidy,
sort of a photo shoot.
You know,
it's done a little bit ironic,
but a,
you know,
there's a lot of heart in it.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I'm going to be there.
Uh,
what is it?
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
uh,
Thursday.
June 10th is my birthday by the way.
Okay,
so,
and I'm going to spend it on the road,
like some lonely sailor.
No,
actually I don't even know why I took the Gig on my birthday.
Ana.
Why did cause I owned it tax man.
Yay.
The tax man.
I don't know how you get rich and,
and I know why people fucking steal from people because that's the only way to
get over the hump.
Every time I think I'm going to get over the hump him.
I'm like my on fucking easy street.
The fucking Goddamn IRS shows up.
You know it gives me the fucking right there.
Fred,
the right there.
Fred to my fucking nuts right there.
Fred.
I just made my dog jumps.
Sorry about that dude.
Sorry.
Right there Fred.
That was actually a catchphrase in my family right there,
Fred and what that was.
That was actually from a Flintstones episode,
Flintstones episode where Fred was trying to fucking do a,
you guys haven't had that yet.
They just have a fucking like catchphrase and only your family gets,
you know,
maybe you guys could send me into those.
Oh,
that'll,
I'll tell you one of ours,
one of ours in our family was called right there,
Fred.
Yeah.
Everything was going great than the dude gives me the fucking right there,
Fred.
And it was from the Flintstones and Fred,
I don't know what he's doing.
He was trying to impress Wilmoth that he learned how to do magic and he,
and he has this egg and egg does Lino,
a couple little dupes.
He dues and he's like,
all right,
well my,
where is it?
You know,
and he has this,
he has it like buried in his fist and she goes right there,
Fred and she fucking pounded.
She pounded his fist and broke the egg and his hand and exposed him.
You know,
he thought he was the shit and she made an absolute fool out of him and the
proverbial yolk on your face,
but it was in his hand.
So that became that pecan enough that became the right there.
Fred and my family.
Anytime like,
you know,
you think you went in an argument,
you think?
Yeah.
Is there anything funnier than watching a big dog walk across hardwood floors?
I swear to God.
You think they're going across a minefield?
Cleo?
What's wrong with you?
Huh?
You don't like walking across it.
What happened to you?
Did you have a bad experience?
I'll have to say.
I don't even have to say like the entire,
you want to go outside?
I'll have to say as you want to inner ears come up,
Cleo,
you want to,
okay.
You want to go inside?
I'll see if I can get,
get her to how Cleo?
No,
no,
no.
Damn Cleo.
You want to go say
fuck she doing a little death,
Cleo,
you won't go inside.
Oh,
oh,
fucking awesome.
Is that if you guys don't have dogs,
I don't know why you don't have a dog and get a breed that fucking house.
I make it do that every time.
That was actually just
ah,
it's just fucking awesome.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's plow ahead.
What the hell was it?
I was talking about catchphrases,
but I was going to tell you something else.
I Dunno.
I was speaking to my dog.
You know what the F my fucking landlord found out I had a dog.
Neither my landlord is listening to this podcast or the,
or the old fuck downstairs ratted me out.
I don't know what,
but I let it go.
I let it go
cause you know,
make,
I have my coats,
I have my,
I don't name names and I don't yell at old people.
All right?
I may talk shit about him on my podcast.
Hey,
remember that crazy lady,
that lady,
that crazy lady that I was telling you about my neighborhood.
Uh,
I was driving down the street the other day and I just saw her fucking laying on
the grass
screaming,
just fighting off like invisible.
I don't know what
okay.
And uh,
I
like,
I haven't left and I don't know how long it was so fucking funny.
I mean,
I feel bad for her and shit,
but like,
uh,
are you gonna stand like the street I live on is a quiet street and I'm driving
down this quiet street in my hybrid,
which is actually even choir,
my hybrid,
the fucking Bose headphones of automobiles and it's just quiet.
You know,
I got the windows down.
It's the perfect day.
You don't need a c,
you don't need the windows up.
It's just why you live in California.
It's this fucking awesome day and you know,
fucking blue skies,
just,
just a beautiful day.
I'm just cruising down the street,
could just got a bunch of shit done.
I'm feeling good.
And all of a sudden I just,
I just,
you know,
as I'm coming up on her,
I can't see her because this car's parked in the side of the road.
I just say this saw this faint,
like,
okay,
and I'm like you.
And it was so fucking bizarre.
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And then I just cut the ends up being like this just for car gap between cars
parked on the side of the road and I can't see this big SUV.
And right when I come around the side of it,
there's this crazy lady on her back like a fucking cockroach that can't get up
do you think?
Just flailing in slow motion.
I love Fred Sanford each limb one at a time.
And it was just so fucking bizarre,
but she was so committed and she was so into it.
And so just fighting something off.
It was,
it was just,
it was fucked.
Like,
it was so peaceful,
so beautiful.
What a day.
And all of a sudden I fucking drove by and I just started fucking laughing and
it was like,
it was just a guilt free left.
That was a guilt free left.
You know,
I didn't feel bad.
I feel bad that she's out there,
but like,
I like to think that I'm mature enough to know that either way.
The,
that's funny.
Right?
Am I a bad person?
I probably am.
I don't know.
Well that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
I didn't get back to the way that I didn't get back to the flyers.
Uh,
I didn't get back to,
you know,
I'm going to talk right until my phone call comes.
I got a phone call here at 11,
which is in four minutes.
Um,
what was I gonna say?
I fucking,
uh,
getting back to the flyers and the,
the Blackhawks.
Okay.
It's a great series you guys really should watch right now.
Black Hawks just went up three,
two.
They are,
they are one game away.
Slick sleeve.
Willits law.
You know,
they always do that.
Yeah.
Quarter to eight minutes away from handling the curse,
um,
from ending basically 50 years of frustration for these people.
Okay.
And you know,
to the fact that they have like,
you know,
some of the original players,
they have like five people left from their fucking team that aren't even dead
yet from the last time that they played.
MMM.
I'll tell you what's Austin's Bobby Hill.
Bobby Hall still looks like I can't figure out if he looks like,
if he'd still beat the shit out of you.
It looks like the calm.
He's in that weird aging process where he still looks like he could beat the
shit out of you yet.
He also looks like he signed the declaration,
the declaration of independence,
which would have been hilarious if I didn't fucking stutter.
Goddammit.
I'm dumb.
Um,
so I gotta be honest with you.
I'm going to be happy for either a free the team.
It's going to be a shame that when you guys had got to lose and,
uh,
you know,
I'm looking forward to a more games Celtics,
Lakers,
uh,
got respect for the fucking Lakers,
man.
They're a hell of a squad.
And a,
I was off.
I was really off.
I got to say it again.
I said Pog who saw was going to get fucking raped and the NBA finals and uh,
I'm most impressed with him.
Andrew,
uh,
buying him.
Is that his name?
Andrew.
I'm not a basketball guy.
I'm total bandwagon here.
I'm a fucking hockey guy.
Um,
for years people have been saying what the fuck this guy going to do?
But he keeps hurting his knees and it seems like he's,
he's coming into his own and I don't know,
man.
It's going to be tough at the Celtics beat him.
It's going to be really fucking impressive because,
uh,
I think they younger and they're,
they're quicker,
but we always find a way.
We find a way to win ugly.
That's what we do.
So we do.
What about ray ray reining in those threes?
You know,
and I had the whole game on mute.
I probably missed a lot of the excitement of listen to the crowd go crazy,
but I don't give a fuck.
That's how I have to do it so I can survive.
So,
uh,
they have it.
That is the podcast for this week.
Come in a,
come check me out of Caroline's this week in New York City.
Also next week I'm going to be at the Improv out here in Los Angeles,
Los Angelinos and uh,
I haven't put it up yet,
but I haven't,
um,
years,
people have been asking me to come out to San Diego and a,
I'm going to be at the La Jolla,
uh,
um,
comedy store the first weekend in August.
I don't have the fucking dates in front of me here.
Let me just check the map.
July,
August,
uh,
the sixth and seventh,
I'm going to be out there.
So all you guys out there who have been asking me to come down there,
I'm finally coming down there and hope you show up.
Uh,
you can check out my new hour as shit.
And as far as I know,
that might be right around the time when,
uh,
let it go,
my special become an awning comedy central.
And then you'll watch it and be like,
Oh wow,
that fucking guy's hilarious.
I'm going to come down.
Seemed the club.
And I hit you over the head with a new fucking hour cause that's how I do it.
All right,
if fucks now I'm talking shit.
I'll see you guys next week.
Have a great week and get yourself a dog.
Get a big dog that tippy toes across the fucking a hardwood floors.
It'll how for you once a day,
it'll keep you happy,
keep you happy.
You know bankers.
Okay.
[inaudible].